maxime bernier l'électron libre c'est
fini la police est correct pour moi
maxime a jamais été
legault dit gibbs de ses maximes il fait
maintenant cavalier seul et veut séduire
à droite de la droite annulation et lui
donner le carbone taxe
elle regarda monsieur prend pas les
caches mady lui a fait de la politique
autrement ça c'est vrai muse
constitution et ne pousse pas le
prochain chef andrew scheer
c'est un grand rêve brisé à moins d'un
pour cent des votes derrière le
vainqueur en gros scheer maxime bernier
voit s'effondrer son plan de prendre la
tête du parti conservateur
[Musique]
oui on va ne rien faire pendant
plusieurs mois
bernier rumine son échec on sentait une
frustration de bourgogne a donc à la
limite ça pourrait être interprété comme
je veux pas qu and grouchy les u6 le
sénateur conservateur claude carignan
était un ses supporteurs pendant la
course à la chefferie
maxime est aujourd'hui était un peu la
personne qui avait ses propres opinions
et qui suivaient pas nécessairement les
moments où on doit être uni donc maxime
a jamais été le gode équipe c'est maxime
un an après sa défaite
maxime bernier publie ce qu'on pourrait
appeler les tweets de la rupture
si message une charge en règle contre le
multiculturalisme
il dénonce le culte de la diversité et
le multiculturalisme extrêmes plus de
diversité ne nous rendra pas plus forts
écrit-il cela détruira notre pays
l'attaqué dirigée officiellement contre
trudeau mais elle vise aussi le parti
conservateur
il claque la porte et fonde le parti
populaire du canada et plusieurs genres
de populisme et je fais de la politique
basée sur des principes mais ça peut
être un populiste intelligent et c'est
fini le pôle c'est correct
pour moi le populisme c'est dans l'air
du temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la peur des immigrants et de la
mondialisation le rejet des élites et
des médias la vague mobilise des foules
en europe elle apporte et donald trump
au pouvoir
quels sont les ressorts du populisme
intelligente de maxime bernier
janvier dans le stationnement d'un
relais routier de calgary ses membres
des gilets jaunes canadien prépare une
manifestation pour exprimer la colère de
l'ouest contre ottawa leur mouvement
fort d'environ cent mille membres sur
facebook est inspiré par celui des
gilets jaunes qui a embrasé la france de
griefs sont variées pour la construction
de pipelines pour la fermeture de la
frontière contre la menace d'un
gouvernement mondial
rock'n'roll
[Musique]
et s'en vont klaxonner leur colère
devant le centre ville de calgary
on promet pour bientôt un grand convoi à
destination d'ottawa
[Musique]
presque au même moment dans un hôtel non
loin de là une autre manifestation de la
grogne albertaine l'invité d'honneur
maxime bernier c'est une assemblée du
freedom comme sur le petit parking un
nouveau parti provincial
ultraconservateur qui flirte avec
l'indépendance de l'alberta
la manifestation des gis légende déborde
ici les partisans du mouvement sont
quelques-uns à être séduits par le
message de maxime bernier
celui ci doit tout de même laissé à la
porte une pancarte jugée trop agressive
nous interceptons maxime bernier alors
qu'il se prépare à prendre la parole le
chef d'un parti national canadien qui
est ici dans l'ensemble à saveur
séparatiste on l'a un peu bizarre j'ai
une invitation par derrick le chef de ce
parti là et ça me donne une tribune
intéressante pour aller parler de
l'expérience du québec et comment on
peut faire en sorte pour unir le canada
et non pas le détruire
l'albertain du québec aime bien son
surnom
ici on rage contre la péréquation qui
redistribue une partie de la richesse
pétrolière de l'ouest au bénéfice de
province moins riches comme le québec et
le nouveau brunswick d'égalisation
formula il martèle qu'il ne se gênerait
pas pour utiliser les pouvoirs de la
constitution pour imposer un pipeline
aux provinces qui s'y opposent
awad new energy les politiques
économiques que nous proposons nous
parti populaire c'est quelque chose que
les algues vertes et m c'est un
authentique programme libertario réduire
les taxes réduire le rôle de l'état et
abolir toutes subventions aux
entreprises
l'ancien chef du parti wildrose une
formation provinciale alberton
aujourd'hui disparu campé à droite parti
conservateur
elle anime une quotidienne où elle
entend jour après jour les
récriminations des albertains d'année
aujourd'hui à calgary
il a marqué des points
maxime bernier m publier des tweets sur
le climat qui résonne favorablement au
pays des sables bitumineux de co2 at-il
écrit n'est pas de la pollution c'est ce
que nous produisons en respirant il
retirait le canada de l'accord de paris
sur le climat et abolirait la taxe
carbone ce n'est qu'un des thèmes qui
l'exploitent sur twitter son outil de
communication quotidien sur lequel ils
cherchaient visiblement à publier des
messages qui font des vagues comme celui
ci où il se moque de la rectitude
politique en visant la journée du hidjab
le lendemain maxime bernier fait le
décompte des like fier de dire que son
tweet a été aimée 425 fois en français
et 6500 fois en anglais we fuji le
programme du parti populaire dénoncent
la politique actuelle d'immigration qui
va changer de force la culture et le
tissu social du canada je pense que de
l'opportunisme politique donc qui voit
qu'une certaine frange de la population
qui accroche on tient des messages ou là
un disque au plus deux d'extrême droite
ou de droite
je pensais dangereux plus que payant
parce que ça parlait des dérives et je
pense que quand on en joue sur ce
terrain là on laisse deux brûlés
le sujet de l'immigration fait
facilement réagir les franges plus
extrémistes de la société qui gérait ses
fréquentations est un défi pour le jeune
parti de maxime bernier newton dernier
la section albertaine du parti populaire
avait dû exclure un suprémaciste blanc
qui avait joint sert à maxime bernier a
aussi voulu prendre ses distances avec
la meute en refusant de prendre la
parole lors d'une manifestation
organisée par ce gros mais la
controverse a rattrapé son plus proche
conseiller martin masse pour de vieux
écrits comme celui ci sur une femme en
burqa
si personne ne veut ni la soigner ni
éduquer ses enfants elle n'aura d'autre
choix que de s'habiller comme une
personne civilisée ou de retourner dans
son pays
maxime bernier a vigoureusement défendu
son collaborateur à propos des
migrations il parle souvent de valeurs
canadiennes
ces valeurs là qui nous unit c'est quoi
ces les valeurs de liberté de
responsabilité d'équité d'égalité de
l'homme et la femme et d'égalité devant
la loi
et donc ces valeurs des valeurs basées
sur le christianisme c'est trop fou le
dire gdo chrétienne après la pause
comment maxime bernier séduit la droite
religieuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laureline tyler thomson est une
candidate vedette du parti de maxime
bernier
c'est une ex télévangéliste bien connu
en colombie-britannique lors des
élections partielles du 25 février dans
trois circonscriptions au canada c'est
elle qui a offert aux parties sa
meilleure performance avec près de 11 %
des voix madame thompson dit qu'elle a
été écarté du parti conservateur à cause
de ses déclarations trop controversé
contre l'avortement et en matière
d'éducation sexuelle
il n'y a pas si longtemps on associer
pas maxime bernier à la moralité
conservatrice plutôt libérale sur ces
questions maxime bernier a déjà
participé par exemple au défilé de la
fierté gaie pourtant partie de la droite
morale et religieuse trouve sa place à
ses côtés
consacré au parti populaire du canada
raymond high as tu t'étais un des
principaux organisateurs du parti
populaire dans le grand montréal
je vais pas parler c'est lui la star et
la militer pour le respect des valeurs
chrétiennes dans les programmes
d'éducation sexuelle au nom de
l'association des parents catholiques du
québec fait tout de l'idéologie de la
technique mais quand on dit à un enfant
s'était créé des del à la maternelle
d'où vient l'enfant du spermatozoïde et
de l'ovule le parti populaire du canada
investit les réseaux alternative de
droite et les réseaux chrétiens ne font
pas exception
comme ici sûreté au vox qui se veut une
voix pour dieu sur internet
moi je respecte les droits des
parlementaires de déplacer un projet de
loi ce n'importe quel sujet même s'il
refuse de se prononcer pour ou contre
l'avortement sont partis tend la main
aux militants pro vie
oui si vous élisez maxime bernier même
si dans son programme il y ait à l'epad
avortement quoi que ce soit il ya un
risque qu'on re débattent l'avortement
parce qu'il ya un risque qu'un député
pro vie dépose un projet voit là dessus
je pose problème bonjour tout le monde
le web et les médias sociaux déclaration
sur son téléphone
maxime bernier sort des sentiers battus
de la communication politique au canada
il a pris exemple sur donald trump dit
il en tournée dans les radios de québec
regarde à monsieur trempe allait bien
choisi lui ai fait de la politique
autrement ça c'est vrai oui et on rit
est élu donc je partage pas tous et
prisa position mais la comparaison qui
peut être peut-être vrai c'est la
manière dont on utilise les médias
sociaux pendant la préparation de notre
reportage nous avons demandé une
entrevue de fond avec maxime bernier
nous avons aussi fait des demandes
d'entrevue à plusieurs de ses
collaborateurs
aucun d'eux n'a été autorisé à nous
parler
nous avons rattrapé maxime bernier lors
d'un lunch bénéfices à outremont
question maintenant qu'il concerne notre
travail monsieur bernier votre service
de communication devenue sur une liste
noire parce que vous êtes aux
conventions n'ont sûrement pas longtemps
je suis ici mais je vous parle
aujourd'hui je parle tous les médias que
ce soit les médias traditionnels ou des
médias non traditionnels est ce qu'on
peut voir rendez vous pour une entrevue
seront avec vous absolument je suis en
campagne et je me promène partout dans
le canada
[Musique]
quand la caméra ne roule plus le plaisir
annoncée de ce rendez-vous s'évanouit
c'est martin masse son premier
conseiller qui nous le fait savoir avec
quoi donc ces réseaux c'est un sujet qui
soulève particulièrement ses supporteurs
[Applaudissements]
si le 1er février
maxime bernier est allé encore plus loin
il promet que cette journaliste de siby
s'y perdra son emploi s'il prend le
pouvoir
un peu partout dans le monde
le dénigrement de la presse est devenu
un cheval de bataille des mouvements
populistes
[Musique]
non
le convoi pour le pétrole partie de
l'alberta a fait du bruit au delà du
nombre des participants
c'est une tribune de glucides pour le
chef et son nouveau parti seul et
n'impose pas après ce discours prononcé
exclusivement en anglais à douchy
revient à son tour parler aux
manifestants
le petro 2 les chemins de fer
le chef conservateur devra par la suite
répondre aux critiques lui reprochant
d'avoir pris la parole devant vichy
légende qui accueillent dans leurs rangs
des militants d'extrême droite
la question se pose le parti
conservateur devra t'il se positionner
plus à droite pour contrer un possible
effet bernier
mais pour le moment cet effet peine à se
manifester une division du vote
potentiellement favorable aux libéraux
est constamment remises sur le nez de
maxime bernier d'un bout à l'autre du
pays
quoi qu'il en soit maxime bernier a tiré
une vidéo promotionnelle de sa rencontre
avec les manifestants une étape de plus
sur un chemin ou ce qu'il aime et c'est
encore à le suivre
[Musique]